alors
[Musique]
tu comprendras
le pouvoir de l'Invisible
[Applaudissements]
peu ne dort pas
s'il y a bien plus en jeu ici que
nos vies
pour toute la Terre du Milieu
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu es,
je suis une garde basse qui
ne t'écoute pas
encore  sera enfin connu pour qui vous
êtes vraiment pour vous notre Seigneur
est revenu et les Southlands sont en
grave danger les Southlands
la fin
cette ombre
elle met une petite chose qui passe
ressemble à la nuit
prochaine le soleil se couchera sur votre passé
vous le verrez se relever elfes et
nains travaillant ensemble hé et c'est
comme ça que ça commence
restez fidèles les uns aux autres ce sera un
rappel de notre force Des
héros parmi nous attendent même maintenant d'
éclater
je servirai je
servirai ce soir un essai de plus  nous attend
je n'ai pas traversé cet océan amer
nous sommes sur le point de créer un nouveau
type
de gamme les anneaux de puissance ne sont désormais
diffusés que sur la vidéo Prime